today I'm going to be talking about
budgeting for strawberry production
my name is Jesse Rowan I'm on the farm
and agribusiness team as well as the
commercial Horticulture team so I work
primarily with fruit and vegetable
Growers
um in the central part of the state
and so today I'm going to talk about I'm
going to talk about the budget that we
have available online
through the extension website and then
I'm going to kind of break it down by
the different input costs within that
budget and the different input costs
related to Strawberry production and
then I'm going to touch on how you can
budget for your farm
for your own form
all right so to start with the budget we
have online it looks a lot like this
it's just that first summary page and
it's actually
um it's from 2019. we are in the process
of getting an updated version put online
but
um if you can't tell a lot of things
have changed in the past few years a lot
of prices have gone up but this budget
still really provides a good list a good
summary of the expected cost uh just the
expected expenses you would have on one
acre of strawberries
some of the assumptions within this
Enterprise budget that's already online
um or that we use six foot spacing that
all these strawberries are sold for The
Fresh Market that plastic mulch is used
um and within this budget they also
account for
Harvest labor it's not a U-Pick
operation this is if you were to hire
crop workers to harvest your entire crop
of strawberries and also within this
budget they account for cover crops
which is great that's something
chip really looks as big on and he could
touch on it more if anyone had questions
about it
but also within this budget this online
already
so the first page of it is and is that
summary that I just showed you on the
first page the second third and fourth
page it kind of it lists out the field
operations and it looks a little
intimidating if you're looking at this
and you see a lot of numbers and a lot
of decimals
but really it's really good to look at
to see the operation you know what
activity you might be doing like a soil
test you know applying fertilizer apply
in line or plant in your cover crops and
it also shows you in what month you
could do that and this there's a little
give and take for you know people
growing strawberries in north or south
Alabama but it's a really good guide a
good estimate to look at to kind of just
show you the activities when you can
expect to do them
um
and kind of in the order of which you
should do things like they have soil
tests and then later on in the season I
think it's in
March they have
um they want you to do a plant tissue
sample so it really just gives you the
optimal optimal time in which to do
these activities
um and it also gives a good estimate of
about how many Harvest hours you could
expect you know
um a lot of
labor hour estimates that are really
that would be really beneficial to
someone planning on starting a
strawberry operation
so I wanted to talk next about the input
cost
uh so since his budget is made uh since
it's from 2019
you would expect a lot of things have
gone up since then you know covet has
occurred since then
and then all the supply chain issues
that occurred then and have still kind
of hung around some so that's going to
be things like fertilizer that's going
to be something that you can look at
this budget you can look at this budget
summary but know that the prices are
going to be a lot higher for things like
fertilizer chemicals plants labor and
fuel
I mean you can look at the price of
diesel fuel in this 2019 budget and see
there's 270 a gallon
that's not where we're at today as
lovely as that would be and you can also
see they accounted for 11 an hour for a
lot of their labor that's it's really
it's really going to be tough to come by
any labor nowadays uh where you're
paying them 11 an hour
um and then some of the obvious things
are like fertilizer chemicals and plants
those have gone up over the past couple
years especially fertilizer and
chemicals have gone up with the fuel
fuel cost increases
um just as energy goes up in price those
are going to correlate right along with
it
oh
sorry I went back a couple of slides
so first I'm going to talk about
fertilizer the it's right on the nose
everyone knows that the price of
fertilizer has gone up drastically in
the past couple years so
in that older budget they estimated that
you'd spend about
665 dollars on an acre of strawberries
yes no longer the case
I can't give exact numbers for y'all
today because that's going to depend on
your soil test and you know what kind of
fertilizer what you need for your farm
what you need for your land but the USDA
economic research service they estimated
and this is just around nitrogen
fertilizers but they estimated that
all three kinds of nitrogen fertilizer
are going to go up you know over 100
percent you can see in this graph this
graph is just showing how urea prices
have changed over the past two years so
you see that purple line is 20 20. you
know pretty steady a little up and down
but pretty pretty bag unsteady the green
line 2021 you see around September the
end the last quarter of last year it
skyrocketed and then you see the red
line is 2022. continues to go up it
starts at 920 an acre uh I mean 920 a
ton for urea and then you can see it's
just angling up so it's really it's just
going to get higher
um and that's really just something to
take into consideration when you're
planning for your strawberry operation
or really any kind of operation
and something that extension really
encourages is testing your stool that
way you're accurately applying the
correct amount of fertilizer you're not
spending money on fertilizer that you
don't need
that's not going to be absorbed well in
your soil
and so a soil sample that is really just
going to give you a really good idea of
what you need to put in your soil and
also a couple times a year with a
strawberry operation you could have a
tissue sample sent off and test for the
nutrients
in that exact tissue sample um so the
cost for a soil sample is around seven
dollars
that's pretty inexpensive to me to know
exactly what my land needs and
especially as the prices of fertilizer
just continue to go up
paying seven dollars to know exactly
what you need to spend on fertilizer
is a pretty good deal
um that way you're not spending money on
it extra fertilizer that you're not
going to need
um so really this just kind of goes to
show that
when you're trying to budget for any
kind of fruit or vegetable production
you know and prices are going up in all
these different input sections
the more the more accurate and the more
tailored you can make those costs to
your farm the better the more efficient
you can be the better because really at
the end of the day that's all you can do
you can control what you can control you
can't control the fertilizer process you
can't make them go down can't make the
price of fuel go down but all you can do
is use just what you need not spending
money on things you don't need and just
having as efficiently run operation as
you can
um and I also just wanted to throw in
that you can spend anywhere between ten
or eighty dollars for a tissue sample
and that can give you a really good idea
of the nutrients your plants themselves
are taking up
so the next thing I wanted to touch on
um the next input cost that's gone up
has been labor
and this graph you don't have to look at
all the numbers per se but really just
focusing on the fact that that green
line is the number of crop workers that
have been uh oh sorry the green line is
the dollars per hour that those uh that
crop workers are being paid you can see
it in 2015 it was pretty low it was
around 11 an hour
um at the tail end of 2021 the wage for
those workers was around 15 an hour
you can look at that blue one that just
shows the number of workers has stayed
pretty steady it dips down
and this is really related to fruit and
vegetable production so the number of
crop workers is going to get down around
January December of every year because
that's just when we don't have as many
crop workers in the U.S a lot of them
come through on a program that's around
10 months long so
um they may go back to their home for a
couple months a year but the top of
those Peaks that's going to show that's
a really good representation of the
number of crop workers just hired in the
U.S and you can see the top of this
Peaks it stayed pretty steady it goes It
goes across pretty well it was a little
lower in 2020 because covet threw off
everything but you can see that the
number of workers has stayed pretty
steady yet the price that we're paying
those workers continues to go up it does
not dip down much just steadily
increasing
um and another just another segment of
that budget that has increased along
with everything else row cover this may
not be as drastic of a price increase as
some of the other objects
um it was priced around a thousand
dollars a roll in 2019
I've looked up similar roles in 2022 I
seen some for around 1200 1400
um and you have that initial investment
but it is something that you can reuse
so it's not something that you might
have to buy every year or a couple times
a year or something you can get a lot of
uses out of
um but also something specific to
Strawberry production so you have a lot
of labor involved in using a row cover
and a row cover is necessary in
Strawberry production whenever it gets
below freezing temperatures you have to
cover up the strawberry so they're not
damaged by any of the frogs
um or any of the cold temperatures and
so it's really important to have Labor
um even if you were to have a you pick
operation and you didn't have a hired
crew of people to pick your crops you
still need to have enough people to lay
this row row cover over your
strawberries
um and you're going to need access to
that crew
um at really specific at really key time
so it's not something that's labor
intensive all the time but around
January and February it's going to be
really labor intensive at Key times and
it's going to be really important that
you have enough labor to put that over
your crops in a timely manner
foreign
I can't skim over this when I'm talking
about strawberry production
something that I've heard from Growers
uh from colleagues is that you cannot
spare fungicides that's something
we really don't want you to skimp on
anything
um you don't need to skimp on IPM or
fungicides but I've been told that
especially fungicides that something
that's really important in Strawberry
production in keeping those berries and
keeping those plants healthy looking so
it's something that's really crucial to
the operation so chemical prices have
gone up over the past couple years
um just as some of these supply chain
issues continue
um and so a piece of advice I usually
give Farmers if they're worried about
the process some of their chemicals
going up
um or even sometimes of a certain
chemical being available when they need
it I just tell them to buy it when they
can even if it's
January and it's something that you
don't need for four months if you see it
at the store and you know you're going
to use it
um
you know you're going to need it go
ahead and buy it because
you don't necessarily want to rely on
this uh
supply chain you know all these
chemicals that are imported you don't
want to have to rely on that
um and then not be able to get something
when you need it
foreign
and also so rotation of strawberries is
important
um it's something
I know that not every Farm does this but
if sufficient land is available it's
something that can really benefit you
and so before going into a strawberry
growing operation
um this is really something that you
would like to have planned out a lot of
people
they like to leave your land without
strawberries for a couple of years but
some people just rotate every other year
but just some kind of rotation is really
beneficial to kind of relieves some of
that disease pressure insect pressure
and it can lead to better productivity I
mean there are ways to
still increase your productivity if you
can't rotate but it's just something
that's generally encouraged
and also plastic culture this is another
part of strawberry production that is an
investment every year
um so just the capital investment in the
plastic mulch you know the labor
investment of shaping the beds laying it
down
um that's something that's really it's
really uh just gonna be a cost you need
to be prepared for have it planned in
your budget
um
so I've got the prices for a couple of
years ago that may not help you now and
I know there's so many different places
you can get plastic culture I've seen
some online I've seen some uh
2400 foot rolls I think it was four foot
wide for around 130 dollars that I've
used in some other budgets when I'm
including the price of uh of plastic
mulch
but also some farmers will plant another
crop into that plastic mold which after
the strawberries to kind of just spread
the cost of it onto another crop anytime
you can do that it's just instead of
attributing the whole cost of this
plastic mulch for strawberries you can
spread it over strawberries or onions
strawberries and whatever the other crop
may be and it just kind of spreads out
that investment of something that it's
not something that can be reused the
next year is something that's just good
for one year
all right and so the cost of plants
that's going to be
your biggest investment I believe when
it comes to Strawberry production
that's something
um so I have a range on here listed I've
I've seen them this year for around 45
to 50 cents a plan I've seen them lower
than that seeing them around 30 cents 35
cents per plant
um
but that's really just to show that in
the older budget from 2019 I think they
were selling for
I think it was 24 or 23 cents per plant
and just to show that in some places the
price of plants have doubled
um and these are something that's
typically purchased locally if you want
to get organic plugs that usually is
done they usually have to be brought in
from somewhere outside of Alabama
and so you're going to be planting I did
a little math on here not to scare
anyone but so if you're planting around
1400 plugs per acre I mean 14 000 plugs
per acre and say they're 50 cents each
you're spending around seven thousand
dollars just on your plants
um
that is just a huge investment in terms
of money spent on Plants I can't think
of a whole lot of other uh fruit and
vegetable production where you're
spending that kind of money on just the
plant itself just you know the plug
um so it's really it's a major
investment
um that you really need to I say to plan
around it but this would kind of be the
basis of your plan
um and you would need to plan everything
else around this to make sure that
you're managing everything as well as
you can to take care of these plants
that are your major investment
and so another thing that is a really a
really big cost in Strawberry production
would be labor so
nobody's denying that strawberry
strawberry production is a really uh
it's a it's a crop that Demands a lot of
investment initial investment so we
covered the investment of
the plants and you know and then
everything else that goes along with
that production system but also you have
a lot of labor involved in
pre-harvest and can have a lot of Labor
in the post-harvest section of your farm
so
pre-harvest you're going to have you
know land prep like you do with anything
planting is going to be pretty labor
intensive because you have to have
someone personally putting each plug
into those holes I I guess you could
have a planter but it's typically done
by hand
um scouting spraying other management
involved so
irrigation would fall under that
Scouting For pests Scouting For diseases
um just anything involved in the
management that's going to be a lot of
labor involved and then also like I
mentioned previously Frost protection so
having you're just having those periods
of time where you have to get a crew of
people to roll out these row covers and
put sandbags or put anything down you
know to hold it in place
there's going to be a good bit of Labor
in that and I mean that can change year
to year depending on how many freezes
you have I mean how many you have late
into the year that could really damage
your uh your plants but that's just it
it's labor it can't be overlooked that
you're gonna need to have Labor
accounted for you know all of these
tasks and post Harvest you can or you
cannot have a lot of uh labor yourself
in the operation so
like in the budget I mentioned at the
beginning of this presentation they
accounted for Harvest labor
um and I think they accounted for it was
about 30 hours a week harvesting
uh yeah 30 hours per week in the months
of April and May
and so that can kind of be gone around
if you were to have a U-Pick operation
um it can't go around it completely
because even with the U-Pick operation
you're going to need a
you're gonna want to have some of them
picked
um or at least gleaned after by some of
the people on your farm a lot of you
pick operations will offer you pick and
then also some pre-picked buckets
um so it's not like you can depend just
on consumers to come out there and pick
the berries for themselves but that can
decrease that can take away so much of
the labor that you need
um if you were to have a you pick
operation and that can actually I mean
that can save you money
um you know save you from hiring more
people to harvest all those berries
because you know they're time sensitive
dairies don't have a super long shelf
life it's something they need to be
peaked when they need to be peaked
um and it's a lot of intense production
in April and May
and so you know having a you pick
operation just can save you a lot of
money on hiring a uh you know a
harvesting crew but you're still going
to need some labor to glean you know to
offer some pre-picked buckets most
likely and then to clean up afterwards
that's just something that can be
avoided
and so this next slide I took a little
inspiration from Chip East
um
Chip's always talking about people
Farmers getting the retail dollar and
that's really that's how you can get the
most bang for your book as a strawberry
producer so the retail prices are going
to be higher than processed or wholesale
prices that's kind of a given that's
that's uh usually the case in a lot and
a lot of fruits you know if you're
selling direct to a consumer you can
charge a higher price
um
and
they can also be used for value-added
products if you were to have some that
didn't sell which I don't often hear I
hear about a lot of strawberry Farmers
selling out
um or at least that's how it's been the
past couple weeks but if you had some or
if you just wanted to use some for a
value-added product to sell later in the
year
um or to sell you know alongside your
fresh strawberries that's something they
could be used for and like I mentioned
before
um a U-Pick operation that can save on
harvest labor and it can also save on
marketing costs because if you were to
have a you pick operation
consumers are driving to your farm
they're picking the berries they're
paying for that gallon bucket however
much of strawberries and then they're
leaving
um and while you have you know
something extra for that would be you
know you have extra people on your farm
that you wouldn't normally have but
you're also from the farmer's point of
view you're not having to go out
um
and drive to a farmer's market you're
not having to drive to a store and
deliver your berries
um you're not really having to go much
of anywhere I mean you're still probably
going to spend some money on signs maybe
some advertisements but it you could
save a lot on marketing costs as well as
harvest labor so that's just something
to consider
um especially if you if you want to have
a strawberry operation
um and you know you know that you can't
uh you don't have access to as much
labor as you would need to harvest them
all that's just a direction you could
turn your operation in
um and save money on a couple of things
and so I'm going to skip the next slide
just because I'm a little short on time
and I wanted to talk about how you can
budget for your farm
and so
um
this screenshot that I have up here
right now that's how most of our
Horticultural budgets typically look
um the ones that we've gone through and
redone they all look like this and this
isn't all of it I just took a grab of
you know the top half of it so that you
can see how it's laid out
that you have receipts at the top you
have all your variable costs and then
below this you would have your fixed
cost listed
and so uh we should have a strawberry
budget out like this uh in a couple
months or so but
um
it's something if you were to already
have an operation you wouldn't even
necessarily have to have this to keep
track or to keep a budget for your farm
you could keep track of it in a similar
manner on uh you know on your farm
computer and so this one is set up
because uh the two columns in blue you
can change you can change the numbers
change quantity the cost per unit of
certain items and then get a different
cost per acre but if you were to do this
on your own Farm you could keep track of
so I would start out I would keep track
of the strawberries you sell either you
pick
um it would be helpful to keep track of
how many you sell that are actually you
pick and how many you sell that are
pre-picked buckets that way you know you
can just keep an eye on how consumers
are buying
um and then you can list all of your own
costs under this
um but something like this these budgets
that we provide online they provide you
a good list of your variable cost and
what you should be keeping track of some
of them are even listed at zero they're
listed on there just so you can go
through yourself and say like a land
rent if you're not renting a land then
you could just leave that zero across
that whole line but if you are renting
the land that's where you would need to
input that cost
but it's really helpful just to provide
a list of what you need to create a
budget but you can do this yourself for
your own Farm by keeping track of just
how much you spend on soil tests your
plants uh you know any other tests you
may do like a soil uh like a tissue
analysis and then how much you spend on
fertilizer lime
um especially if someone if you were to
keep track of it this year you can look
at it next year see if things have gone
up or if they've gone back down or if
things have
have gotten even crazier but it's just
it's really good to keep track of these
kind of things you can look at them year
after year
um
really the Enterprise budget is really
beneficial for someone planning the one
that we have online is really good for
someone planning to get into strawberry
production but if you already have a
farm if you started and then a couple
years into it it's really going to help
you to keep this budget to keep this
type of budget for your own operation
the numbers that we put in it are all
estimates because every Farm is
different every Farmer's different
everyone has different assets different
strengths
um and just different costs you know
some farmer may may need a ton of
fertilizer may need to amend their soil
so much say it's been uh
it's it's been empty for a few years and
they're having you know completely
amended from scratch and to say someone
has lended they have taken care of and
amended for five or ten years
um you know your costs are just going to
be different based on your land the
farmer himself you know and his
management practices and how he wants to
go about things
um but keeping track of those things can
really
help you budget for the next year and
that's essentially uh what you want to
do you want to keep track of your
expenses year after year and then use
them when you're planning for the next
year
um it really it can help you notice
changes year to year noticing Trends and
it helps you better plan out your
expenses for the following year and
that's that's what we all want we all
want to have a better idea of what we're
going to spend so we can have a better
idea of what we can earn from it
all right that's that's the end of my
presentation I hope I didn't
go too long
um but I have my contact information
listed up here if you have any questions
feel free to reach out to me